hi there steve kaufman here again
i want to continue this discussion on uh
you know
how we can become fluent or can we
become fluent in three months in a in a
new language
and
i would say that you can become fluent
in a new language
and it depends on a number of factors
first and foremost it depends on how
similar the language is to one that you
already speak obviously a spanish person
learning portuguese or vice versa or a
german person lurking learning dutch
these people have
a tremendous advantage
because of the similarity of the
vocabulary the second thing is just how
much time you're able to put into the
language so if you're if you're living
in the country and you're with people
all day long
uh this is going to make it easier for
you
the third consideration is just what
your goals are
and
and this gets back this idea of becoming
fluent just by by talking a lot
if we look at the
common european language excuse me
common european framework we see six
quite clear definitions of
levels of language competence so if your
definition of fluency is
the ability to converse on familiar
subjects
uh
and again it depends on how different
the language is to your own
um
you know this might be a very limited
range
of subjects or it might be somewhat
larger if if you already have a lot of
the vocabulary because as i say you're
going from spanish to portuguese or vice
versa
so depending on your definition and your
goals this sort of some degree of
fluency is certainly achievable
going from certain languages to certain
other languages especially if you're
located in the country where the
language is spoken but let's have a look
at what the
european framework says
you know a2 which is beginner two is
described as can understand sentences
and frequently used expressions related
to areas of most immediate relevance
very basic personal and family
information shopping local geography
employment
can communicate in simple and routine
tasks blah blah blah
so i mean that's probably where you
would get to
uh the average learner in the average
situation
uh b1 which is intermediate one
which
you know to get there in three months it
suggests according to the
common european framework you would have
to be able to understand the main points
of clear standard input on familiar
matters regularly encountered in work
school leisure etc can deal with most
situations likely to arise
whilst traveling in an area
can produce simple connected text that
is writing presumably
on topics which are familiar or of
personal interest can describe
experiences
events dreams hopes ambitions and
briefly give reasons and explanation
explanations for opinions and plans
that's b1
i think that's hard to get to you know
if yeah but i think people can do it
there's no question that people can do
it
uh and so you can be quite fluent again
within this sort of limited range of
vocabulary unless you're going from very
very closely related languages
now once we move up to uh you know even
b2 which is still in this sort of
intermediate area is described by the
common european framework as can
understand the main ideas of complex
text on both concrete and abstract
topics including technical discussions
in his or her field of specialization
that's b2 can interact with a degree of
fluency and spontaneity that makes
regular interaction with native speakers
quite possible without strain without
strain for either party now we're
getting really quite close to
sort of genuine fluency and in terms of
writing can produce clear detailed text
on a wide range of subjects and explain
a viewpoint on a topical issue giving
the advantages and disadvantages of
various
options so that's b2 you're still in the
intermediate area so now you know
there's differences between being
advanced and being fluent i think you
can be fluent at a lower level of
of complexity
uh but when you're advanced when you're
in the sort of sea area european common
european framework which by the way i
think is very good and i will leave the
reference to wikipedia
here
uh if you see that what the how they
describe the advanced person
c1 can understand a wide range of
demanding longer texts and recognize
implicit meaning can express him herself
fluently and spontaneously without much
obvious searching for expressions can
use language flexibly and effectively
for social academic and professional
purposes can produce clear
well-structured detailed text here we're
talking writing again on complex
subjects showing controlled use of
organizational patterns connectors and
cohesive devices this is c1 so this is
the first level of advanced
and then just to finish off c2 which is
the ultimate
target which i don't think many people
uh achieve and i don't think that
possibly i'm there in french because i
studied in france for three years but uh
c2 can understand with ease virtually
everything heard or read can summarize
information from different spoken and
written sources reconstructing arguments
and accounts in a coherent presentation
can express him herself spontaneously
very fluently and precisely
differentiating finer shades of meaning
even in the most complex situations all
right
so
what we see here is that that there
should be a difference between
fluency in terms of flowing
comfort level within a limited range of
subject matter
and advanced learners so
can we get fluent in three months it
depends what your goals are
i think a lot of people when they learn
languages i think a lot of people just
want to be comfortable talking to the
people that they'll meet on their next
trip to mexico
so that can be achieved i think fairly
quickly
i think a lot of
more ambitious learners myself included
academic learners would like to achieve
you'd like to get into that c1c2 area
they would like to be
essentially as
comfortable in the language as an
educated
native speaker
so how do you get there you don't get
there just by talking and a lot of
people i know it's quite common even in
japan people want to go to their ego
eikaiwa class and they just want to talk
and it's my belief and i think this is
ultimately the what i think is the most
important point in this whole discussion
and that is that
if your goal is to achieve this
uh degree of of even the b2 the advanced
intermediate level
you have to do a lot of reading
a lot of reading and and i like
combining reading with listening
because after all
words were originally spoken before they
were written down
and and so and i think we learn better
if we do both reading and listening so i
like to
always have both the audio and the text
available uh
plus
uh a listing is a lot easier to do i can
do it whenever i want i can do it while
i'm doing other tasks reading is more of
a dedicated task
and if we look at what happens with
native speakers
it has been proven through research that
those people who read a lot
do better nothing tracks
to job performance and academic
performance as much as
how literate people are and you know
they divide the native speaking
population into five
sort of levels of literacy the top 20
percent the second twenty percent and so
forth uh
apparently forty percent of the
population in north america and in most
countries in europe
uh don't read well enough to perform
effectively in a modern information
society now the top 20
of people who read the most and the best
they do the best professionally
academically so if that's the case for
people in their native language i think
it has to be equally the case uh when we
are talking about learning
the language that those people use and
and wanting to perform at the level that
the educated person performs at in that
language
uh it's furthermore i i want to
emphasize that the connection between
listening and reading
uh they have found that when kids learn
to read in school initially they all
kind of learn at the same speed those
that
you know don't have any particular you
know dyslexia or other problems because
they learn to decode at the same time
and all of a sudden they can decode
these words however by grade three or
grade four all of a sudden there's a
great
uh separation that takes place and those
kids who grew up in families
where the parents spoke to them on a
variety of subjects
they have a bigger vocabulary and
therefore they their reading takes off
because they know a lot of words as they
decode they discover these words and of
course the more words that you know in a
context the more you're able to infer
meaning and
and guess at the meaning of of new words
so that it's a real example of the rich
get richer and the poor get poorer now
an adult learner of course
uh
trying to catch up with the native
speakers a bit behind the eight ball so
to speak is at a disadvantage however
the adult learner if the adult learner
is well read in his or her own language
that adult learner will have an easier
time acquiring vocabulary in the new
language if you aren't even familiar
with the concept the word in your own
language you'll have an awfully tough
time learning it in the new language so
what i want to stress here is that to
get to these levels of c1 and c2
you have to do a lot of reading and the
listening in a in effect supports
reading
uh because what you're doing is you're
exposing yourself to words
and if your focus is entirely just on
speaking you will necessarily stay
within a limited range
of vocabulary because you'll presumably
meet with the same people talk about
those things that you're comfortable
talking about
and you will pick up some additional
vocabulary as you hear them speak but it
won't be as effective
in increasing your vocabulary as massive
input so what i want to end up with here
is the the suggestion that if people are
serious about reaching a high level in
the language c1 c2
massive listening and reading is going
to give you the base
from which you can then develop the
speaking skills and the writing skills
which obviously have to be worked as
well but without the base of words
without the base of vocabulary without
the exposure to the language through
massive listening and reading you will
not be able to develop that
ability to produce the language because
you won't have the words and i think
that in all of this discussion about
fluent in three months or what can you
achieve
um
the key thing is let's not forget
that there are no shortcuts
that in order to achieve the level that
i described as c1 and c2 you have to
invest a lot of time in listening and
reading
so thank you very much and
i look forward to comments and questions
bye for